MARC TOBIAS KUNISCH:
Android Instant Apps
make it possible for users to
access your app without having
to install it first.
Imagine users
opening your app just
by clicking on a link in
an email or a text message.
We've recently made
Android Instant Apps
available to all
Android developers.
To take full advantage of this,
we have some best practices
to help you make your
Instant Apps user
experience as great as
that in your installed app,
or maybe even better.
You can find all this and more
at the URL in the description
below.
It's important to keep in
mind that by enabling your app
to run instantly
without installation,
you're not creating
another additional app.
We're thinking of Instant
Apps as another way
to use the app your users
already know and love.
It's the same app, just
without installation.
By adding the ability to
access your app directly
from a link, a search
result, or another app,
it's much easier for users
to engage with your app
and get excited about it.
If they decide to keep your app
on their device permanently,
they can then install it right
from within the Instant App.
The ability to launch an app
without having to install it
provides an enormous
opportunity.
For a long time,
app developers have
focused on the number
of app installations
as a proxy for the metrics their
business really cares about.
Without installation,
users simply
weren't able to engage with the
developers' offerings at all.
Removing this barrier
to entry enables
you to think about the
metrics your business really
cares about.
Your audience is now just
one tap away from engaging
with your service.
Your Instant App is just another
mode your app can run in,
so don't branch your UI and
make any unnecessary changes
regarding the layout,
interface, design, or experience
of your Instant App.
The transition from
instant to installed mode
after installation should
be as smooth and seamless
as possible.
Your users should have a
rich and full app experience,
even if they haven't
installed your app.
Rather than thinking of Instant
Apps as a limiting factor
to what your audience
can do, think of it
as an opportunity to get them
to your functionality quicker
and a way to foster your
relationship with them.
Avoid prompting your users to
install the app when they're
in the middle of a task.
They'll be much more
inclined to place your app
onto their device
permanently after it
has had the opportunity
to prove its usefulness.
Refrain from bouncing
them back and forth
between your Instant App and
your mobile web offerings.
You can probably tell
by now Instant Apps
are all about removing
friction for your users
and getting them closer
to your functionality.
Think about ways you can
remove further barriers
for your users.
For example, wait
until users can
see the benefit of
making an account
and signing in until the value
of doing so becomes apparent.
Asking users to create an
account after installation
seems like a small
additional ask
when they've already gone
through the app installation
flow and are only
just getting started.
However, when they are
coming from a link looking
for specific content
or functionality,
being asked to register
can feel very disruptive.
Additionally, make sure
to use available APIs
to make your and your
user's life easier.
Using Google's Smart
Lock, for example,
makes signing up and
signing in a much simpler
and straightforward experience.
In summary, we really
think that Instant Apps
will unlock a lot of opportunity
to engage your audience more
directly.
Users will be able
to focus on what
it is they want to
accomplish, rather
than having to spend time
maintaining and updating apps
on their phone.
We're super excited to
see what you come up with.
Everything I talked about
here, and much more,
you can find on
g.co/instantapps.
Thanks for watching.